within 40 minutes of posting the
Kickstarter for banjo-kazooie spiritual
successor ukulele had exploded past its
target goal and currently as of writing
this is now beyond the 2 million dollar
mark
but this is decidedly not just another
Kickstarter game developer platonic has
promised not only to carry on the torch
of the rareware golden age that gave us
Donkey Kong Country banjo-kazooie
banjo-tooie Conker's Bad Fur Day Perfect
Dark Viva Pinata Donkey Kong 64 and the
like but to do so in a way that
incorporates the collective experience
of these ex rareware vets in the 15
years since banjo to me was released and
to clarify my position on the matter
this is a mind-bendingly exciting
prospect the banjo kazooie games
ignoring that one which we're not going
to talk about here for some of the best
platforming titles of my youth they
blended simplistic cartoonish themes
with a deep expansive very visually
stunning world and the depth of gameplay
that transcended even the untouchable
gem super mario 64 on my first
playthrough it felt as if the run
infinitude of new moves and
transformations that Banjo and Kazooie
could discover with a wealth of secrets
to be uncovered by each one however
since banjo tooie is release a true
sequel hasn't been openly discussed
composer grant kirkhope and a handful of
others from the original games have
mentioned their interest in more banjo
but beyond that all we've had is I'll
anticipate the groans of 3d platforming
is dead and why not do something new
with the following if you really think
3d platforming is a genre devoid of
innovation I'll direct your attention to
one of the few things Nintendo has done
right as of late the Super Mario Galaxy
games in Mario 3d World these games
while remaining firmly grounded in much
of what made games like Mario 64 great
innovated on a genre that had seemingly
been done to death by putting new spin
on old mechanics and ideas and
subverting traditional platforming
expectations and with the openness of
banjo kazooie's massive moveset and
magical transformations it's open season
for platonic to innovate but it's not
just the mechanics at play here play
tonics commitment to delivering a
satisfying final product shines forth
and many other manifestations it's been
confirmed that not only will ukulele
make use of that disney-esque dynamic
music theming that made the banjo game
so immersive but the music will also be
composed by rare legend grant kirkhope
of the banjo kazooie fame and the
illustrious david wise the man
responsible for among many other gems
this little
platonic have also stated their
intention to give each character a hyper
detailed backstory complete with
rivalries alliances friends foes and
subjective morality z' that may paint
them as evil in this game but set them
up to be the protagonist in a future
game into that point they're fully
intending some of these characters to
populate future games and not
necessarily only within the 3d
platforming genre the comparison they
made was that this will be a Marvel
Universe level of detail with each
character opening their own world of
possibilities and if there's even a
shred of truth to that that I'm weeping
with excitement over this the worlds
these characters will inhabit are as of
yet a mystery the only pieces of the
various worlds we've seen are in these
still images and a bit of demo footage
from what looks like your basic starter
world jungle level but discovery of new
worlds will be a huge component of the
excitement in any banjo kazooie
spiritual successor remember the first
time you entered gobies desert for mad
monster mansion those moments put me on
the edge of my seat as I tried to guess
what sort of Mambo transformation or new
scale or strange quests and characters
awaited me within each new realm further
platonic has confirmed that these levels
will grow as you progress through the
game ozone will most likely either be a
much larger or a completely different
place when you're finished than when you
began and in traditional banjo-kazooie
form a massive hub world will tie beus
realms together with each new section
unlocked through collection of pages
and/or the skills you'll acquire in each
level as you progress the collectibles
and secrets will also spill over into
the hub world some of them apparently so
well hidden that platonic are claiming
it'll take months or even years for fans
to find you may call me the static or
idealistic in hell I may very well be
but after consuming every bit of
information platonic is released about
ukulele I'm about 10 times as excited as
I was when I began these gentlemen have
promised to keep what people love about
all rare games not over promise anything
and to listen closely to what fans want
from ukulele in order to craft the most
perfect follow-up to the banjo kazooie
games imaginable and i quite frankly
couldn't be more hyped over it Godspeed
platonic games and while you're at it
Conker's Bad Fur Day too would be really
really nice